CONCERN FOR SO MANY OTHER
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT ISAAC
OMAR?
"GUTFELD!."
>> AMAZING SEASON, NUMBER ONE
RATED OFFENSE IN THE MBA, KYRIE
IRVING, HISTORIC SEASON.
BUT THE BIGGEST VICTORY FOR THE
NETS IS YET TO COME.
P3 THE GREAT VICTORY FOR A
NEW YORK IS WHEN YOU FINALLY
LEAVE.
[APPLAUSE]
♪ ♪
>> Greg: AND YET ANOTHER SCOOP
MISSED BY WOODWARD AND
BERNSTEIN, CAROL LONEY CLAIMS
THAT DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T WANT
ANY SECRET SERVICE AGENTS ON ITS
DETAIL BUT THAT'S HARD HITTING
JOURNALISM.
IF THESE ALLEGATIONS PROVE TRUE,
NOT ONLY WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
GUILTY OF INSTITUTIONAL FAT
SHAMING, HE ALSO SINGLE-HANDEDLY
CRUSH THE LIFELONG DREAMS OF A
SHY CHUNKY YOUNG LAD BY THE NAME
OF BRIAN.
THAT WAS A LONG WAY FOR A JOB.
NOW THIS IS FROM A BOOK ON THE
SECRET SERVICE, BUT THE ONLY
BUZZ BEING GENERATED IS ABOUT
THE MOST INTERESTING MAN ON THE
PLANET, THAT OLD GUY WHO DRINKS
GO PSYCHES, TRUMP.
ACCORDING TO THE BOOK, TRUMP
ONCE SAID "I WANT THESE FAT GUYS
OFF MY DETAIL."
HE ADDED, HOW ARE THEY GOING TO
PROTECT ME AND MY FAMILY IF THEY
CAN'T RUN DOWN THE STREETS?
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO ADD
ANYTHING TO THIS.
ONCE AGAIN, SOMEONE IS TRYING TO
SELL A BOOK BASED ON A
CONVERSATION THAT LIKELY CANNOT
BE VERIFIED BY SOMEONE ON
RECORD.
AND WHAT HAPPENS?
EVERYBODY IN THE PRESS CALLS FOR
THE SAME SOURCE TO VERIFY IT.
THAT IS THEIR CONFIRMATION.
A MISS INFORMATION LOOP.
BUT WE DON'T DO THAT HERE AT
"GUTFELD!," MAINLY BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE BUDGET FOR A
PHONE.
AND I'M REALLY LAZY.
BUT ALSO THERE IS NO NEED TO
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT QUOTE IS
100% FACTUAL.
OF COURSE TRUMP WOULD SAY HE
DOESN'T WANT FAT GUYS ON HIS
DETAIL, BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE
ALL SAY IF WE WERE THE PRESIDENT
TOO.
HE IS US, WE ARE HIM, HE IS
RIGHT.
ONE OF THE ONLY REASONS TO BE
PRESIDENT IS THE PARKS.
THIS IS NOT A GREAT JOB, HALF
THE COUNTRY HATES YOU AND YOU
ALWAYS HAVE TO WEAR A SUIT AND
TIE, EVEN TO BED.
AND UNLESS YOU ARE A LEFT-WING
SHIELD, THE MEDIA DEVISES YOU.
YOU CAN EVEN LOOK AT A WOMAN
WITHOUT BEING ACCUSED OF
SOMETHING AND IF YOU DO GET
LUCKY, HOW CAN YOU BE INTIMATE
WHEN THERE'S THREE MEN WITH GUNS
NEARBY.
I MEAN, I CAN'T COME I PRACTICE
A LOT IN PRISON.
AND GOD FORBID YOU WANT TO HAVE
A DRINK, YOU'D HAVE TO PUT THE
WHISKEY AND A JUICE BOX WHICH IS
SOMETHING I LEARNED FROM THE
GALS ON OUTNUMBERED.
HAVING SECRET SERVICE IS
PRIORITY NUMBER ONE.
AS PRESIDENT, YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING.
HEY, LET'S DRIVE BY MY OLD
GUIDANCE COUNSELOR'S HOUSE.
AND IF ANYONE COMES FOR YOU, THE
SECRET SERVICE CAN SHOOT THEM IN
THE FACE.
I THINK THAT'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
I DIDN'T CHECK, BUT I'M
ASSUMING.
WHEN I BECOME PRESIDENT I DON'T
WANT AN AGENT WHO LOOKS LIKE A
COKE MACHINE WITH A HEAD.
I WANT HIM OR HER TO LOOK LIKE
DOLPH LUNDGREN DURING THE
ALLEGED STEROID PHASE ARE CARL
WEATHERS AND THE ACTION JACKSON
PHASE.
WHAT A BODY ON THAT, AND HE
NEEDED ONE TO FIGHT CRAIG T
NELSON, NOBODY REMEMBERS GREG T
NELSON.
SEE YOU NEED A SHOW OF FORCE,
NOT A SHOW OF FLAB.
YOU WANT CLINT EASTWOOD, NOT
CLINT HOWARD.
AND REMEMBER, THE MOVIE WAS
CALLED "IN THE LINE OF FIRE,"
NOT "IN THE LINE OF
DAIRY QUEEN."
THIS IS WHY TRUMP WAS SO
BELOVED, HE WOULD SAY WHAT YOU
WOULD SAY, HE DIDN'T LOWER AT A
BAR, HE SPOKE LIKE YOU DO WHEN
YOU ARE AT A BAR.
OF COURSE, TRUMP ALSO DIDN'T
WANT SHORT PEOPLE THERE EITHER.
SO AS A MEMBER OF THAT COMMUNITY
WHOSE HEIGHT HAS BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO ON
DATING SHOWS, SHOULD I THROW A
TANTRUM?
SHOULD I DRAW MYSELF IN A
TEAPOT?
OR HANG MYSELF FROM A BOWLING
TROPHY?
NO, I GOT IT.
IF YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE A
BULLET FOR THE PRESIDENT, IT'S
KIND OF UNFAIR IF THE PRESIDENT
IS A TALLER TARGET THAN YOU.
IT SEEMS LIKE A SAYING THAT
SHOULD BE ON THE CHECKLIST OF
HUMAN SHIELDS.
IS HE IN REASONABLY GOOD SHAPE?
CHECK.
AS HE TALLER THAN PETER DRINK
LEDGE?
CHECK.
OF COURSE, THIS SERVICE HAS
STANDARDS FOR AGENTS IN THE
FIELD.
SOME AGENTS -- THEY ALSO HAVE
OFFICE JOBS.
AND THAT IS WHERE I WOULD WORK.
I KNOW MY PLACE, I CAN CATCH A
TYPO, BUT NOT A BULLET.
I WILL TAKE ONE FROM FOR THE
TEAM AS LONG AS IT'S A SPICED
LATTE WITH SCAM.
PLUS I WOULD HAVE IS REALLY COOL
SECRET CODE NAME LIKE "SORRY
LADIES, HE'S MARRIED."
THIS IS MEANT TO PORTRAY TRUMP
AS INTOLERANT CLAIMING HE TRIED
TO REMOVE STATS HE DEEMED TO FAT
OR TOO SHORT.
BOO-HOO, NOBODY MINDED WHEN HE
ENFORCE THE SAME STANDARDS FOR
THE MISS UNIVERSE PAGEANT.
TELLING MEN WHO ARE TOO FAT OR
TOO SHORT THAT YOU DIDN'T MAKE
THE CUTS, THAT HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME.
AMONG WOMEN, IT'S KNOWN AS
DATING.
BACK ME UP.
ALL RIGHT, DON'T, FINE.
I WONDER WHAT HER ANGRY WHITE
MALE THANKS.
♪ ♪
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I LEARNED
IN LIFE, NOT EVERYONE CAN DO
ANYTHING.
WHEN I WAS A KID, WANTED TO BE A
BASEBALL PLAYER OR A FIREMEN.
I GUESS I'M NOT SUITED TO EITHER
ONE OF THOSE.
THERE'S A LOT I CAN'T DO.
BUT IF YOU WANT A GUY WHO CAN
WHITTLE A STICK INTO SOMETHING
RECOGNIZABLE, I AM YOUR MAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
HUMAN HAND.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: INTOLERANT JERK.
I WONDER WHAT HER ANGRY BLACK
MALE THINKS.
♪ ♪
>> WHAT IT IS?
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE DIDN'T
WANT A SHORT FAT GUY IS A
BODYGUARD?
NO [BLEEP].
NEITHER WOULD I.
♪ ♪
SPEWING ONCE AGAIN THE MEDIA
EXPERIENCING THEIR TRADEMARK
TRUMP WITHDRAWAL.
SIX THE NEXT SIX AND ANOTHER
DOPEY EXPERT.
BUT REMEMBER THIS, TRUMP MAY NOT
BE A FAN OF IMPERFECT PHYSIQUES,
BUT HE NEVER DENIGRATED THE
WORKING GUY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU WANT A CONTRAST?
TRY JOE BIDEN'S RECENT COMMENTS
COMMEMORATING NATIONAL POLICE
WEEK.
AFTER A PERFUNCTORY EXPRESSION
OF GRATITUDE, HE QUOTED DEEP
DISTRESS TOWARDS LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHICH IS BEEN EXASPERATED BY THE
RECENT DEATHS OF SEVERAL BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE AT THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HE'S LIKE A GUY WITH A SORE
TOOTH.
HE JUST COULDN'T LEAVE IT ALONE.
THANKS FOR THAT, JOE.
REMIND ME NOT TO HAVE YOU GIVE
THE EULOGY AT MY FUNERAL.
OF COURSE, THE SLANDERING OF THE
PLEA SEEMS WAY WORSE THEN
WANTING TO REASONABLY FIT PEOPLE
TO PROTECT YOU AND YOUR COUNTRY.
AND OF COURSE, IT WAS TRUMP'S
INSULT THAT GETS MORE COVERAGE.
DO YOU THINK TRUMP CARES WHAT
THE POSITIVE BODY IMAGE CROWD
THANKS?
FAT CHANCE.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
WE WERE WORRIED HE WOULDN'T COME
BACK.
DR. DREW PINSKY!
HE'S FROM THE HAWKEYE STATE,
FORMER ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL
MATT WHITAKER!
SHE LIKES HER PRINCE HARRY.
HE'S SO HUGE GETTING ON HIS GOOD
SIDE TAKES TWO TRIPS, POST ON
FOX NATION, TYRUS!
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, WE ARE
GOING TO WEIGH IN ON SOME
DANGEROUS TERRITORY.
TO SPEAK I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT HOMOEROTIC OPENING.
I KNOW MY WIFE ENJOYED IT.
>> Greg: SOUNDS VERY
DISGUSTING.
>> I HEAR YOU.
>> Greg: OKAY, YOU ARE A
DOCTOR, OR SO YOU CLAIM.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANY PROOF.
>> HOW DARE YOU.
DO WE HAVE TO GO THERE?
>> Greg: JUST GIVE ME A
PRESCRIPTION PAD AND EVERYTHING
WILL BE DONE.
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE OVERWEIGHT
ARE PHYSICALLY LESS CAPABLE IN
THIS CAPABLE DOWN MY PARTICULAR
JOB?
>> YES, RIGHT?
WHEN PEOPLE BECOME
SECRET SERVICE THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH TESTING BEARD BUT
APPARENTLY THEY HAVE STANDARDS
AND THESE GUYS ALL PASSED IT,
BUT IT DOES SOUND LIKE TRUMP.
IT REALLY SOUNDS LIKE HIM BEING
HIM WHERE EVERYBODY GETS FIRED
IF THEY ARE NOT UP TO HIS
SPECIFIC LITTLE QUALIFICATION.
BY THE WAY, YOU MENTION THESE
MISS UNIVERSE PAGEANT, I BELIEVE
I'M THE ONLY GUSTY FAD THAT WAS
ACTUALLY A JUDGE ON THE
MISS UNIVERSE PAGEANT.
HE SAT BEHIND ME WITH MILANI AND
IT WAS AN INTERESTING
EXPERIENCE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE STRANGEST
DOCTOR I'VE EVER MET.
>> I THANK YOU.
>> Greg: I SAVED A PATIENT ON
THE PLANE.
WELL, I WAS A JUDGE ON THE
PAGEANT.
YOU MAKE ME SICK, DR. DREW.
I KID, I KID.
ALL RIGHT.
MAPS, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU.
THIS IS UNLIKE THE OTHER FOX
SHOWS.
>> NOW, IT IS NOT.
YOU WILL SHE WEAR.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK -- I
BELIEVE HE SAID THIS, AND YOU
WORKED WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> I WAS.
WENT FROM MISS UNIVERSE TWO
MISS USA OR WHATEVER.
OBVIOUSLY HE LIKES FIT
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BEING JACKED I
MIGHT ADD.
BILL BARR IS VERY OBVIOUSLY
JACKED.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT, WHEN
I HAD THAT MOMENT WHERE I HAD A
SECURITY DETAIL OF FBI AGENTS,
THEY WERE ALL VERY FIT AND
WILLING TO BREAK A LOT OF NECKS.
I THINK IT IS GOOD.
AND IN THE PRESIDENT'S DEFENSE,
IT IS A VISUAL MEDIUM.
AND SO HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT HE HAD PEOPLE THAT LOOKED
LIKE ME AROUND HIM.
>> Greg: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
ALMOST BECAUSE HE IT IS A
PRODUCT OF OUR CULTURE AND A
PRODUCT OF TELEVISION, TYRUS,
YOU WERE A BODYGUARD.
>> YES, I WAS.
AND I'M WITH HIM.
I DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE WITH HIM
NOT WANTING SHORT FAT GUYS OR
WHOEVER IS AROUND HIM BECAUSE
BEING A BODYGUARD TAKES A
SPECIAL KIND OF DUDE.
ALTHOUGH I DID MY JOB TO THE
BEST OF MY ABILITY, THERE WAS A
WAS A LITTLE VOICE IN THE BACK
OF MY HEAD, IF THEY --
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T EVEN LIKE HIS MUSIC THAT
MUCH.
HERE'S MY RESUME, TWO WEEKS, I'M
OUT.
>> Greg: SOMEBODY COULD
LITERALLY YELL "DONE" EVERY
5 MINUTES IN THE ENTOURAGE YOU
WERE TRAVELING WITH.
IT'S BECAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU
ALWAYS FIND OUT WHO'S REALLY GOT
IT.
I DISAGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT A
LITTLE BIT, BUT IT WASN'T ALWAYS
THE OTHER BIG GUYS I WOULD RELY
ON.
I USUALLY WORKED WITH SOMEONE
FROM YOUR SIZE BECAUSE HE COULD
SEE THINGS I DIDN'T.
>> Greg: YOU MEAN THE GROUND?
>> HE SEES BODIES, PEOPLE'S
WAISTBANDS.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S IMPORTANT, BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHO'S TOTING AND WHO'S NOT.
SPEW AND GOT IT, I CAN SEE THE
GUN.
>> YOU CAN SEE IT.
AND THEN A LITTLE VOICE, IT'S
LIKE -- YOU PULL ON, TYRUS, YES
GREG?
OKAY, THANK YOU GREG.
AND THEN WE GO GET HIM.
>> Greg: I COULD TRAVEL ON
YOUR SHOULDERS LIKE A LITTLE
WOODLAND NYMPH.
KAT, DO YOU REMEMBER THE
BODYGUARDS FOR QADDAFI?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE HOT GIRLS?
>> YOU TO TALK ABOUT MY FAVORITE
PART OF THE STORY WHICH IS THAT
APPARENTLY THESE BODYGUARDS WERE
SO HOT THAT TIFFANY TRUMP BROKE
UP WITH HER BOYFRIEND AND
STARTED SPENDING A LOT OF ALONE
TIME WITH ONE OF THE BODYGUARDS
AND NOBODY TALKS ABOUT TIFFANY
TRUMP ENOUGH BECAUSE I AM MORE
AND MORE CONVINCED THAT SHE IS
AWESOME.
YOU JUST SAID THAT TRUMP IS SO
RUTHLESS AND HE IS, BUT I THINK
IT'S NOTHING COMPARED TO WHOLE
RUTHLESS TIFFANY IS.
I'M SERIOUS.
AND YOU KNOW, JANUARY 19TH RIGHT
BEFORE BIDEN'S INAUGURATION,
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF STUFF GOING
ON IN HER FAMILY, RIGHT?
WHAT IS SHE DO?
SHE GOES TO INSTAGRAM AND
ANNOUNCES HER ENGAGEMENT TO
ANOTHER GUY WHO SHE MET PARTY
AND AT LINDSAY LOHAN'S BEACH
CLUB IN MYKONOS.
LIKE, TRUMP MAY NOT GIVE